[Music]
before we start this video i just want
to mention that only 20.7 percent of you
are subscribed if you enjoy the content
don't forget to like and subscribe to
support the channel thanks hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory today we're going to be
discussing goblins
it probably wouldn't surprise you to
know that the wizarding community
didn't treat goblins with the utmost
respect at all times purebloods outright
hated them
but even the most progressive members of
the wizarding world felt a general
mistrust for the tiny monstrous humanoid
creatures and all of those negative
interactions built up over the years
burdening wizard goblin relations
until the goblins rebelled
in fact if we open up our history books
and look back at the records of goblins
in the wizarding world will find a
series of great rebellions centered
around one common theme
to be treated with equal respect what
were these rebellions and what type of
impact did they have on the wizarding
community
that's what we'll discuss today first
let's go over a bit of goblin wizard
history
for almost all of recorded magical
history goblins in the wizarding world
shared a somewhat peaceful coexistence
although much of goblin's origins isn't
well known by wizard scholars if we take
one look at their distant relatives the
north american pakwaji then we can make
a few safe assumptions
primarily just like humans in the
magical community goblins themselves
must have been a diverse species that
migrated through the known world
while wizards typically treated other
human-like creatures like the giants
with a fair bit of fear they never
really outwardly displayed the same
concern for goblins
just like humans of the ancient world
look down on wizards it seems that from
the earliest records wizards treated
goblins with an equal amount of disdain
throughout the goblin rebellions of the
17th and 18th century this would
manifest itself in new laws like the
code of one to use which we'll talk
about later
but if we spend a bit more time talking
about the early relationship between
wizards and the goblin community we'll
find a peculiar niche that the shorter
more monstrous creatures developed for
themselves goblins were extremely
talented in a handful of things for
starters they were incredibly smart and
the word often used to describe them was
cunning
this combined with their love for
precious metals made them great gold and
silversmiths at one point in the 11th
century the goblins even crafted the
sword of godric gryffindor the very same
blade that would serve the gryffindor's
heirs in the centuries to come
and eventually save harry potter's life
in the chamber of secrets
but that weapons origin is far darker
than you might guess
among the many cultural differences that
brought strife to wizards and goblins in
the middle ages the most contentious
idea was that of ownership to wizards it
was simple if you bought something then
you owned it but the goblins it was far
more complex
purchasing an item no matter how
expensive didn't mean that you owned it
most goblins simply thought that you
were renting the sword or necklace or
what have you for the duration of your
life and goblins could collect it upon
your passing
you see to goblins ownership always
belonged to the creator of the item
and when wizards tried to pass down
their goblin forged heirlooms it wasn't
uncommon for goblins and wizard airs to
come to blows
so when it comes to gryffindor sword you
can see why the goblins would hold a
grudge even before godric died the
sword's creator king ragnarok tried to
manipulate his fellow magical creatures
into stealing the blade that's how much
he loved the weapon
in the years following gryffindor's
death ragnar and his fellow goblins were
insulted even more as the sword stayed
in hogwarts and passed through the hands
of wizard airs for nearly 1 000 years
this tale and others like it were one of
the main sources of resentment that
launched the goblin rebellions centuries
later the goblins continued to thrive
and expanded their community's
specialization as gold and silversmiths
in the year 1474 they opened gringotts
the greatest bank in the wizarding world
there thanks to their cunning goblins
were entrusted with the wealth of the
british wizarding community and even in
harry potter's era over 500 years later
gringotts was the premier bank if you
really think about it carefully goblins
patiently managed the banks and almost
all of the finance in the wizarding
world for that reason and more they were
among the most important beings in the
entire magical community
but even in the decades that followed
gringotts foundation the goblins
continued to suffer harsh treatment from
human wizards
throughout that time there were likely
small protests and battles that the
goblins waged in order to gain rights
but it wasn't until the goblin rebellion
of 1612 that historians decided to pay
attention and record the events
we're not quite certain about the exact
location but it seems that this armed
conflict arose in or around hogsmeade
village
the goblin forces took an in as their
base and ravaged the nearby buildings
setting many of them on fire
the exact number of lives laid down on
both sides has been lost to the years
but the casualties were remarkably high
at least according to hogwarts fifth
year history of magic class and when we
look at the exact cause of this
rebellion there's no shortage of reasons
for why the goblins would have started
it
at a glance the average goblin was far
more important to the lives of wizards
and witches around england although the
same could be said for house elves who
more often than not kept houses clean
and meals on the table goblins were
responsible for far more skilled tasks
goblins forge the most powerful weapons
indestructible armor and through their
natural propensity for hoarding gold
goblins basically kept the entire
wizarding economy moving forward
and yet wizards and witches looked down
on them wherever they went not only that
they almost always refused to teach them
the ways of want lore which meant the
goblins had to accomplish the magical
feats with the far more difficult and
more dangerous technique of wonderless
magic
even the highest court in britain the
wizard gamut refused to allow a goblin a
seat
without fair representation it's likely
that the goblins decided enough was
enough and went on a rampage in the year
1612
but unfortunately for the goblin
community their rebellion only made
matters worse
in response to the display of violence
in hogsmeade the wizarding community of
britain convened and created a series of
laws that restricted non-human magical
creatures the harshest among them was
the new code of wand use which the
wizards council passed less than two
decades after the rebellion
this restricted ones to human wizards
and made it a crime for goblins house
elves giants and other non-humans to
wield them while human wizards simply
hoarded one's law in the centuries
before now it was actually illegal for
goblins to study and possess ones
at a glance you can see how this law
made it almost impossible for goblins to
defend themselves from one armed wizards
and witches
but if you think about it more carefully
the restriction on wand ownership would
completely hinder the ability of goblins
to develop independent of the wizarding
community
and meant that they would always depend
on them
in later years the goblins right group
called the brotherhood of goblins would
protest this law
but even the most progressive human
wizards ignored them following the first
major rebellion in 1612 several more
followed throughout the centuries
again the causes for these were never
explicitly spelled out but if we take a
look at the prejudiced laws of the
ministry of magic you wouldn't have a
hard time at finding a reason for
goblins to rebel
throughout the years the ministry denied
goblins seats on courts they tried to
restrict goblin management at gringotts
and they even attempted to force goblins
into being house elves the goblin
rebellion of 1752 was the next time
goblins stood up for themselves and this
one was even bloodier than the battle at
hogsmeade over a hundred years prior
this time the goblins pledged themselves
to an unlikely alliance a partnership
with werewolves
with the primal beasts on their side the
goblins wreaked havoc across britain the
reigning minister of magic at the time
albert boot was so embarrassed by his
inability to control the goblins that he
was forced to step down and not long
after his replacement a pureblood named
basil flack was forced to retire as well
this goblin rebellion was so terrible
that flak only lasted eight weeks in
office i guess he got a lot of flack it
was flak's successor her face to score
who eventually turned the tides of
battle and stopped the rebellion for
good
in a series of bloody contests gore
defeated both the goblins and werewolves
and even killed one of their greatest
champions in battle a goblin warrior
known as vargot
but only shortly later another
disgruntled goblin hero would arise
this was erg the unclean and he was
probably the only goblin warrior that
harry potter and his classmates knew
about because he was depicted on a
chocolate frog card when we look at
erg's origins we'll actually find some
pretty sad insight into the life of a
goblin
for most of his days it seemed like erg
had to always be careful where he walked
and try his best to avoid eye contact
with human wizards and witches
their never-ending jeers were a constant
threat whenever erg just wanted to walk
to the local grocers or stop by a pub
that served his kind and worse erg had
to mentally prepare himself to endure
physical bullying as well it was after
one of these events when a group of
wizarding students threw him into a body
of water that erg decided enough was
enough
tired of being treated like a
second-class citizen
erg organized his fellow goblins and led
a rebellion
this rebellion like the others before it
was eventually put down with the
superior numbers and ones of the
ministry of magic
but in 1890 another goblin by the name
of ran rock took up arms ranrock
continued the legacy of his ancestors
trying to expand the rights of goblin
kind but ran rock's allies a dark wizard
by the name of victor rookwood showed
that the goblin leader was willing to go
much further than his predecessors
ranrock will be featured as an
antagonist in the new hogwarts legacy
game
ultimately by the time of harry potter's
enrollment at hogwarts the goblin
rebellions were relegated to a short
series of lectures in the history of
magic courses although goblins still
appear to be treated as second-class
citizens they had managed to expand
their rights somewhat perhaps by the
time potter's own children were grown
goblins would be treated with the
respect they deserve
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live